okay calculator fanciers today we have
some you know from the bleeding edge of
calculator innovation some brand new
calculators from staples let's open this
up and see what we've got so we'll make
the traditional incision on one side of
the logo is to not ruin uh the actual
picture there slice that open and we
have oh okay first calculator out of the
bag is already on
and look at um it's okay there's no
further unboxing to be done but it is a
flexible it's a limp some would say uh
calculator you can see they're branded
with staples no box no instructions i
mean what if i want to read
how to use my calculator in a variety of
different languages classic don't do
calculation in a bin that's good and you
can see it is a flexible calculator
let's take it for a spin and see see
what it can do so
what do we have we've got the normal add
subtract multiply and divide we also
have uh this is random it'll add or
subtract if you're doing calculations
and you want an element of random chance
and luck we've got percentage and we've
got m on and m off okay so let's divide
by zero one uh divide by zero equals
error oh okay fantastic uh and i assume
let's just check all the calculator one
uh divided by seven equals a bunch of
numbers times seven equals
oh okay so there's some rounding errors
going on in there but that's i mean
otherwise it's great and it'd be really
useful for all those situations where
you haven't got the space for a normal
rigid calculator so that if you're if
you're traveling you can you can roll
you can look at that you can roll that
up like that right and you can have that
on your person and at a moment's notice
you're like let's calculate it is
flexible you could sew it into your
clothes sewables are all the rage you
can put this right into a coat or if you
can't afford an apple or other smart
watch it actually the contours look at
that
match the arm and so you could just tape
the two ends together there and you've
got a full-on calculator
bracelet and what i quite like is on the
back you can see right through there
look at the cert i mean it pleases me
immensely i mean i almost feel a little
a little it's a little indecent being
able to see all the circuitry like you
can see the connections there when you
hit the button i mean that's
oh that's too much let's just leave that
for now scores for the staples flexible
calculator the display eight digits i'm
going to give it a six
functionality it's very down the line
that's a five accuracy a mere three
ergonomics
it's got to be a 10. cred is flexible
depending on a lot of factors with this
calculator so i'm going to give it a 6
with the standard deviation of 2 and
finally for durability
that is a 10 for a total score of 40.
okay up next we have oh thankfully
something to unbox a binder calculator
wow as you can see anything is better
with a binder it's got a number in the
corner in case you're stuck for what
number to do a calculation with they
provide you with an example number on
the front that's very nice of them and
on the back they remind you it is bet
it's so better what percentage could
they guarantee your satisfaction well
that would be 100
satisfaction guarantee which is there it
doesn't work in any sized bin which is
good to know unless unless you give it a
hug okay so what i'm going to do is very
carefully cut around the calculator
leaving the rest of the box
intact if anyone uh collects for example
star wars figures or like
original baseball cards this is the
traditional way to open them carefully
let's get the bottom bit off there
nice so now you can display separately
the silhouette of where it came from and
now conveniently this whole thing just
have like an exploded bit in your
display case like that to illustrate how
it all went back together okay so let's
get rid of all that so you can see this
is not just a calculator staples
you know they figure this one's rigid
very disappointing will make up for it
you can measure on one side how long
you've been calculating for and then
over here you can attach a variety of
calculator bling on this side
or put it in a binder let's turn it on
first oh here we go okay look at that
okay so we're on and you can see it's a
solar panel one but we'll just double
check even if you lose light you can
continue calculating during an eclipse
that's good to know we've got a square
root key so let's get a quick square
root test two square root times two
square root equals disappointment okay
let's just test out the number that the
example number the serving suggestion on
the packet there so two
four zero eight
nine yep
okay there's woefully inadequate
instructions for what to do oh actually
i see what they're testing this it
actually displays little commas but
unlike you know they're not at the
bottom they're at the top like a little
jaunty little apostrophe or something so
that once again staples innovation in
the field of calculators put the comment
i mean pointless innovation in this case
but you know they're trying everything
final scores for the staples better
binder calculator for display it's got
eight digits so i would give it a six
but for innovations in apostrophes i'll
make that a seven
apostrophe functionality it is a
calculator but it's also got a ruler on
one side you can put it in your ring
binder i mean with a ruler i have to
give it two straight lines 11. accuracy
not great for ergonomics it's nothing
but pointy edges three cred i'd give the
calculator aspect a five but the fact
that it shows you that you keep your
calculator locked away in a binder and
not on display i think it negates that
zero and for durability
okay that's that is unfair i think i
think a five
and finally at the bottom of the staples
sack we have oh my goodness
that is a party in calculator form so
it's not in a box i can't open it up
very sad but i can turn it on right and
let's give it a quick test let's go with
let's do a divisibility test so i'm
going to do 75
i'm going to divide that by 14 and i get
5 and remainder i now subtract the 5 and
then multiply that back up by 14 and i
get ah 4.999992
so the storage is not great and i guess
the great thing about this calculator is
if you get tired of this or it starts to
cause a seizure and you want to do
something else you can flip it over on
the back there's a maze look at that
you've got a little ball there you can
try and get that here we go i can do
this hang on
wait hang on
okay this maze harder than it looks
again staples they are all about
innovation they're not happy to just
make a calculator they've got to put a
maze on the back
for no obvious reason i wish i could
have seen the meeting with like what are
we going to put in the back like a snow
globe or should we have like a maze
let's put a maze that'll do it
unbelievable okay now i'm a little
annoyed it means staples amazing brand
new range of calculators but they've not
given me anything to unbox so i'm not
taking that lying down i'm gonna unbox
the calculator itself
and four okay you can see the calculator
is still on during all of this it is a
live dissection let's unbox it there and
so oh okay so there's the front
transparent part of the calculator
inside we have uh this is where all the
disco is kept in a variety of buttons
here we have the battery and the board
and oh hang on does that come out
oh my goodness okay hang on there we're
out okay so now i can just solve the
maze by picking up the ball and putting
it there scores for the staples maze
calculator display and i guess in terms
of display it's not just the display
really it's i mean the whole thing is on
display i'm going to give that a 10.
functionality
accuracy
not great a four ergonomics is a little
bit
ipod iphone inspired so i'm gonna give
that an eight cred i mean it's pretty
funky i'm gonna give that an eight and
for durability
okay i have i don't even know what
that's meant to be showing okay i'm
gonna give it a oh goodness three
point nine for a total score of 39.9
so there you are the new range of
calculators from staples who are pushing
forward the frontier of what's possible
calculators putting in all new features
that absolutely nobody has asked for
still working